is critical the spanish player he has to
win this game
to have any hopes of uh taking it to
thai breaks young christophe duda is up
by two points you have won both game one
and game two and uh
with the black pieces here i can see
that duda has played very quickly so far
yeah and i must admit i'm very surprised
by the choice of opening by david anton
because this is quite a well-known line
and i'm not sure this exact position but
at least a couple of moves ago duda had
had this in last season's tour and dude
this is part of his solid repertoire the
top players in the world they have
different types of opening repertoires
they have openings for muslim situations
they have openings to be solid and this
is one of duda's favorites when he wants
to be solid and look at this we're about
to see a series of mass exchanges on the
c3 square white knight is about to get
captured and on that square the knights
will come off a set of bishops will come
off maybe even queens will come off and
because david anton needs to win that's
not a good sign exchanges only help
black edge closer to that draw there we
go knights have left the board bishops
have left the board
is david anton gonna trade the queens
now yes he has to white's queen was just
too passive and
duda doesn't even trade the queens he
takes off a pawn he has studied this
before look at his clock time 16 minutes
now gaining time
and uh yeah you're right about him him
studying this game yeah i've actually
looking at this he's played this with
the white pieces himself
against alexander predka
in the world championship i think when i
played against him in 2017 as well dude
i remember he'd played this line already
or i mean the beginning of this line not
up to this position
so yeah david anton i'm surprised he
spent so much time on the clock maybe
just
i would i don't want to say lack of
research but
yeah maybe just a poor opening decision
in a must-win situation
just allowing so many pieces and pawns
to be traded already at this early stage
and also walking into his opponent's
home territory something he's played
many times before yeah and uh
one interesting thing is i'm just
checking above and i can see that duda
has had this with the black pieces as
well against the wesley so you're right
and last year's tour
you have a better memory than me david
they all merge into one i have selective
memory
i only remember the exciting games and
uh my wins not long
okay white's rook's attacking the black
queen but the black queen does have an
escape route um sure
i mean she has two safe squares to run
to now she has to go back on this dark
square diagonal white is a pawn down
temporarily but white can regain the
pawn
and uh the problem is running out of
pieces he needs to win david anton
he's played a great tournament so far i
think he's gained some of the most
points in terms of the tour ratings
and uh yeah it looks like unfortunately
this might be the end of his journey
yeah it does look like this because it's
a very very difficult position
it's just uh to to win actually i mean
it requires a lot of assistance from
your opponent just because of the fact
that like you say there aren't too many
minor pieces on the board and the
position is relatively simple if more
trades are made then the margin for
winning becomes even lower yeah the
problem for white is that if the queens
come off it's going to be a draw if the
rooks come off it's going to be a draw
if the bishops come off it's going to be
a draw you need to keep all the pieces
on the board but it's just going to be
impossible to do that there are too many
open lines black can pretty much force
you to make exchanges
make some trades and i mean the slight
advantage for white here the reason the
evaluation bar tyne gives white a tiny
preference is that white's pawn
structure is better black has two
isolated pawns on the a file and the
d-file white only has one isolated pawn
but it's an insignificant advantage it's
purely symbolic here it doesn't actually
kind of turn into anything tangible and
okay white now offering a queen trade
this could be accepted you don't even
need to go for it yet with black you can
allow this to happen on your own terms
but you can tell even on david anton's
body language he's
he's not too excited about his chances
here he knows that with best play
this should be a draw duda
i think this is quite instructive as
well just taking a timeout calming
himself down he knows he's had a great
opening he's rock-solid in this position
and he's just a few accurate moves away
from the semi-finals and uh i mean still
more than 15 minutes on the club more
than the time he started with in this
game in move 21 and actually seeing the
second game they played as well
duda won that game with more than seven
minutes left on the clock so he's
apparently playing very fast and
confident today
yeah maybe he's been taking a leaf out
of levon aronian's book levon on the
tour last year and
super impressive just playing instantly
playing on his opponent's nerves playing
on their time trouble it takes a lot of
courage to do that it takes a lot of
confidence
to kind of trust your instincts and not
kind of double check everything over
calculate overthink
but uh yeah dude
he slowed down at the right moment as
well just before this queen trade it's
actually the first new move
of of the game you know has this hasn't
been played before most other people you
know wesley actually moved his rook to
the middle of the board and uh that game
actually was a win for wesley eventually
okay this rook yeah the elder rook this
the c2 work we moved to d2 yeah
so white uh white did win that one but i
think that's with a lot of help from
black yeah unfortunately uh so uh david
anton lifting the queen up i don't think
black should rush to trade and take
these off the board
maybe it's okay as well i guess you can
just shuffle your rook across and try
and go after white weak pawn here but
the reason i don't want to do this is
because uh instead of
lifting this rook across if you want to
go for the more natural other rook then
suddenly there is a small problem after
a trade of rooks here you cannot
actually grab this pawn because of
something we've talked about quite a lot
and it's the back ranked checkmate this
king has no breathing space and actually
gets trapped on this back rank
so you can't go for all these trades
immediately you have to be a bit sneaky
about it for black you need to get this
position but you need to have one of
your pawns pushed forward in order for
your king to escape
so in the current position i'm expecting
duda
maybe to trade and
or i was going to say the other option
most likely go active with your queen
you want the queens off but more
importantly you want this pawn off the
board the only way white will win this
game is actually if this pawn later on
becomes a past pawn so you want to
remove all potential danger in the end
game you want to remove it now
so if these pawns get exchanged if this
disappears and this disappears black is
just very very close to the draw now all
right and
some other games
game threes have also started liam lee
against david navarro actually already
the bar over to liam less side they are
tied before this game
so um anything can still happen in that
match and uh ding and van forest also
started game three ding is up by one
point and if he wins this game he will
be ready for
the semi-final to face either magnus
carlsen or hans niemon
all right but in this one it's looking
like it's going to be a short day i
guess then for young christophe duda to
get to the semi-finals
yeah it's looking like that and that's
that's definitely something that we at
home the observer should be feeling but
i can tell you young dude young
christopher should not be thinking like
that instead he needs to be thinking
about the game yeah and just taking that
on a move by move basis he can think
about the semi-finals when he gets there
yeah yeah until then until it's kind of
signed sealed and delivered he needs to
just focus on what needs to be done and
that is just to
address the issues and at the minute as
david highlighted it's just all about
getting rid of that one remaining pawn
on the left side of the board and he's
doing this yeah he's doing it very
effectively and i've been very
dismissive of white's chances oh look at
david anton there he's not happy at all
he knows this is about to be a draw but
um remember duda did lose from a similar
position to this in the past last season
against wesley so that was actually just
due to a big kind of blunder a bit of uh
just maybe
uh miscalculation but this game
we're headed to a draw almost instantly
the queens have come off a set of pawns
have come off
the last two pawns remaining i mean
everything's symmetrical now on the
right side of the board on the right
half all that's remaining of these two
other pawns on the on the queen side and
those guys are destined to get traded
off
white's pawn white's b-porn is eyed up
by the black bishop
is there any hope now that the bishop is
attacking the rook and you know the one
defender of the a7 pawn is going to be
moving
possibly
from his white uh the black rook could
just sidestep one square just attack
that white b pawn or black can even
offer a trade of bishops maybe
you have to be slightly careful in that
regard but actually off trailer bishops
yeah it's still a draw but white does
have one trick at least up his sleeve
uh so okay just move the black rook onto
the b file temporarily go one pawn down
but the white pawn is just too weak
unfortunately so we'll see that happen i
think in a moment
the one trick let's just show it because
it is a bit flashy is that if black does
jump into the center then white does
have an opportunity to play rook takes
pawn really flashy and it's all to do
with the back rank that we mentioned
note how white's king is also a bit
trapped behind its own pawns but black
can't break through because this square
which you want to use to check is
actually covered by white's bishop so
black can't checkmate whereas white
definitely can after rook takes rook
this ends in back rank mate also bishop
takes bishop does end in backrack mate
two you remove this defender in the
corner after brook takes bishop takes
and now checkmate on the next turn the
king trapped so actually that would be a
bit of a blunder and uh i don't think
jan christoph duda is going to fall for
it all he needs to do is move this rook
out of the eye line of the white bishop
for example step it across
or to this square
he's actually setting a trap himself
very sneaky now rook takes pawn is
simply going to be met by a rook check
and now white is the one background
checkmated and uh it's all about these
kings the king's lacking breathing space
lacking air and that means white can't
go pawn hunting and if white can't go
pawn hunting he has to take a timeout
and push this guy forward
that happens and then black now can
simply go after this white b-pawn
go for it with this rook because the
other rook will keep guard of the black
king on the top row on the eighth rank
yeah
totally totally agree with that uh
philosophy and uh
what okay duder does indeed play the
rook movies you suggested
and i just wanted to show you uh a
selfie from cupido baron who
says that garfield from port elizabeth
okay you see rook takes pawn being
played south africa wonders why i make a
big fuss about the chess and not give
him some attention oh we have a jealous
cat
and uh okay so whilst i was talking we
have a big flurry of trades and
everything is level now this is one of
the most drawish positions in chess you
will ever see uh simply all the pawns
are getting traded the rooks have come
off david anton knows his tournament is
about to be over duda is one or two
moves away now from the semi-finals
we're just gonna see the players repeat
there's simply not enough material left
to deliver checkmate and there we go we
have the draw
will we see some celebration from young
christopher do not know he just
runs off and look at david anton
disappointed of course
i think this was the first time dave
danton has made it to the knockout stage
but it ends here in the quarter finals
and the charity cup
now christoph duda has been on fire
today played three